hey guys pari back here with Adam
Chitwood and we've got another tip 2018
review for you this one is for the movie
destroyer stars and Nicole Kidman and is
directed by Karan Kusama who you might
know from the invitation Jennifer's Body
anomie wandering through the stores yeah
I mean Kusama has had a long career of
kind of jumping through genres this one
finds her in another genre it is the
noir thriller and this is very much a
newer Street straight through and
through it's a present-day sweat setting
or but instead of you know Al Pacino or
Robert De Niro in the lead role it's
Nicole Kidman so it puts a very
different spin on the story she plays an
LAPD detective who is very clearly
dealing with issues she's under heavy
makeup her hair is very shaggy she's
very she's very clearly been through a
lot of stuff the film opens with a
murder she seems to know more than she's
letting on
but the rest of the film shows her kind
of investigating this murder but also
flashing back 17 years prior to show the
events that led to kind of her own
destruction when she went undercover
into a very dangerous drug operation
yeah she's scary Nicole Kidman is scary
in this movies but at the same time
carne Kusama and Nicole Kidman through a
performance they do an incredible job
keeping you rooting for her the entire
time even though she is hey she's
difficult to look at she is not only
with all the heavy makeup but she's also
like miserable and means you know it
makes it very difficult to comfortably
watch her on-screen and also you never
know what she's gonna do she is the hero
of this story and I did find myself
fully investing in her to an extent
where yeah I was also interested in
finding out what the heck was going on
here but I wanted to see her come out on
top but I was scared of her I was scared
of her and I was scared of what she was
gonna do next cuz she is really all over
the place and Nicole Kidman completely
loses herself in the role and shout out
to the
Aaron makeup team on this too because
it's not one of those things we're all
like super famous actor let's just bathe
em in makeup and make a thing out of it
it was very very natural looking and it
suited the character to certain things
about her look are tied to things that
happen in the movie and I really
appreciated that touch I think my main
criticism of Destroyer is you know I do
tend to like my stories in a logical
order where I can pick out all the
little pieces and connect it and you
know not necessarily walk away with a
movie that ends with a little bow on top
but in a way where where I feel
satisfied from whatever the mystery
turns out to be and I think when I
walked away I found myself questioning
certain details certain details that
didn't feel like they quite lined up and
also there might have been a small few
that also felt like they disappeared to
me yeah it's a bit of a shaggy narrative
the plot gets a little complicated as it
goes towards the end and and in film
kind of feels like it's droning on a
little bit as a custodian but
thematically I think it's bang on I mean
it's a film about owning your own issues
and owning your own desires and once and
then reaping what you sow from acting on
those desires and once or you know what
you've been doing and everyone kind of
it's about introspection and thinking
about kind of just your own self and
your own life and what you would do when
no one's watching and it's a really
fantastic performance from Kidman really
complicated performance I mean it's it's
in the vein of like breaking bad or Mad
Men or Sopranos it's it's a bad man but
this time it's a woman which makes it
nice to see and it's no coincidence it's
not like Kusama treats it as it's not as
if the character was written as a man
and they just throat a woman in the park
or through a woman part but it's complex
it's complicated one of my favorite
scenes in the entire movie has nothing
to do with the kind of murder supply
yeah
it's a scene between Nicole Kidman and
her daughter and it's just really gut
wrenching
a really bold and brave performance from
Kidman in that regard but I mean it's
it's it's really fascinating it's it's a
film that was you know directed by a
woman shot by a woman I think the editor
was a woman it feels different and
refreshing from anything else you've
seen because we get a lot of ours we get
a lot of crime thrillers some better
than others but this one at the very
least is is different yeah yeah it's
different in all those respects and also
it was it was something else seeing
Nicole Kidman just completely lose
herself in a role like this to such a
disturbing extent but bringing up the
family thing - I think the family and
the the more violent mystery those two
storylines I guess you can call them I
think they they paired together yeah
especially well but ultimately I have to
give this one a b-minus I as I said I
didn't walk away I think is satisfied as
I needed to be with you know where the
the mystery wound up in the very end but
I also suspect that this could be a
repeat of my reaction to the invitation
where the first time I saw the
invitation I walked out just kind of
frustrated by it all I I didn't think it
landed in a place that made the whole
experience worthwhile and I wasn't
thrilled about it but someone convinced
me to give it another go and in that
case knowing the ending completely
changed my experience with everything
that happens in the movie before it and
I mean it's how it's one of my favorite
movies of the past few years and you
know I can't make an accurate prediction
right now but I do suspect that going
back and rewatching destroyer I think
that might change it a little for me and
I might wind up appreciating it more
yeah yeah I love the invitation this is
very different it's not I mean the
cinematography amid cinematography and
the invitation is very controlled
yeah elegant this movie is a lot more
shaggy very grimy los angeles-based very
sunny and I mean Kidman's makeup and
everything is juxtaposed with the scenes
that 17 years prior where she looks like
Nicole Kidman that we know now so we big
and it serves a narrative purpose and
it's very striking to see the difference
I landed on be in my
interview you want more of my thoughts
you can read it on Collider comm along
with a ton of other written reviews that
myself and Michael Berg have been
writing from tiff but yeah it's it's
solid is definitely worth checking out
all righty guys that is our review of
destroyer
keep an eye out for more TIFF coverage
on the collective video YouTube channel
Collider quick and of course Collider
comm as well thanks so much for watching
like and share this review we'll see you
soon
[Music]
you